okay so this uh
is gonna be like quarter speed okay and
he's
he's gonna do whatever whatever he wants
to do
we're gonna we're gonna experiment with
my because my
is space time of course
and of course space time relative to a
given objective or
aim but it has to be dynamic it is
constantly moving
okay what you're going to find is your
kijon
has ill-prepared you um
if you make that the the centerpiece of
your training in other words
when he comes in dynamically you're
gonna do like one thing this my is
already off you see even if i go here
like this
uh because he's cooperating you'll find
you do that against a
truly aggressive person that technique
will not be there they will overpower
you
okay so as as he's going i have to keep
the mind you have to
and this is too fast what i want
so a little slower still keep coming up
so here what i'm doing is making him go
around me
this is one way to say i'm close if i
stay on this line he's going to close
the gap
but by making him go around me i can
have his motion continue without
actually closing
so look for that i keep stepping around
on the spiral
this will not be good it's closing
little by little each time
watch for your uchi's because they will
help you when he gets too close
you can do stripes too
[Music]
and then all this has to be done without
contention
meaning i can't go out of this
i'm always looking for the path
of least resistance
[Music]
uh
so
[Music]
fluidity
over here we're now even
turn around start the spiral
outside there you go
so if you start ballistic keep it going
nope
so round kick two strikes round kick
two stretch hold hot good
again absorb move
move see the difference
you the door
see the difference
okay okay so a couple things
a couple skill sets have to be
pre-developed
so we go and one of them is body reading
so i'll you don't stop no matter what i
say okay
so this is a kick obviously
but you can see it and you see how i
moved out of kicking range and not out
of hand range
so same thing his body moves towards me
but i go hand raised and
i have to be able to read it so some of
the signs
that front foot that little step you
took
right he goes and the head right right
so now look for those stakes if you do
the same thing
and you're going to pay attention to
that front foot he's measuring
do you see so when you when you measure
on the hands your weight tends to come
with the front foot
but when you measure on the kick you
leave your weight behind
do you see that so he's going to do
that same thing boom good and now
so watch the front foot on the way he
shifts his weight and then also watch
his head height
is very common he goes you see the head
came up
so you're you're reading that but every
time you read something
there are such a thing as faith and
faith and so
it's i'm checking it off but i'm not
attached to it
okay so we go in right angle
so he steps slightly out that makes it
very hard for this angle that he's
going to go to so we'll do it again
he steps slightly he's trying to get his
rear kick online you see that so he goes
boom
and i'm moving this way i'm gonna be
okay
if he did the other weight shift so he's
gonna bring his torso with him when he
measures
you see and i do that that time that
would not be okay
because i'd be moving into that hand but
when it's on the kick
i'm going to be out of range of his
hands because he's working with
foot range okay and we'll go on
so maybe he goes and i it up
now i might have to resort to just brace
for impact
okay but even as we brace for impact oh
there's still some absorption in what
i'm doing
i i so what i'm saying is maybe i'm
measuring for that but he came around
which you would see because he turned
his foot
okay so he goes but oh race for impact
you see i'm going
with the direction of the kick goes this
way
then don't leave your foot up
do something else
okay so do it again
so you got you got where
my hair would have been right and that's
going to be that sweet spot branch
you see he's fully extended and this is
where
then you can do things with his hands
so i'm reading the body i could tell
that was a hat there's no need to move
really far
just moving off boom i knew you got
closer last time
okay we'll do something else
sometimes i don't know what he's doing
because he can't decide or he's trying
to get closer or he's setting me up
then you know all of that so get off
that line
he goes i'm gonna move move not gonna
let him set up
move hope
maybe i give him something to think
about
this
keep going
so once you read this initial setup
[Music]
then get your tactile fusion got it
stay with it
stay with it move keep the connection
get it in his body
again
connection right here he's going to turn
in
which he's going to turn
stay you know by really always
look for him to turn tight
okay so read the body he can't read the
body
at least get out of his reticle okay
all right so the first point that was
brought up here
was uh this he he goes i know
and now there's no way so if you look at
this
this is very much akin to when a little
kid
experiences fear they'll shut their eyes
and then they pretend the fear is not
there or they put the blanket over their
head
right it's very very uh ingrained in us
like
there's some connection between what we
see and what we feel
so you have to watch that because
basically i have disconnected from this
person
and i've lost all awareness and all
communion with this person so
you want to think of it this way it's
better to be hit by the strike that you
see hits you than to
have the strike you don't see miss you
out of these two especially in training
this is why we do those sensitivity
drills
when he's all smacking and i keep my
eyes open and i just accept all this
kind of stuff okay so when i'm in in
this drill
i have to keep my eyes open so i can do
these
little movements boom pop i won't have
any chance and i'm going like this the
next one is going to get me
boom okay so it's up to your uke to
train
that out of you um
this is part if you look when you duck
it's all nobody ever ducks like this no
one ever ducks wisely
they always duck and then we break the
first rule which is
i'm letting the my dog go ahead i'm
letting the my
uh become invalid he got too close
okay so force yourself
to look at what's happening so you're
always moving
ha boom
for me
second point is
once i go from this immaterial
connection once i do that
and i get to the material connection
it's all dependent upon now the my has
its third aspect by which it becomes
definable
so if i want to keep connection with
this hand moving back
would be the wrong mind you see if he
pulls back
staying still is the wrong mind so if i
want that connection
i have to move with that hand so i can
keep it in its check
so your mind is dynamic it's not
static third point i want to make
is you chasing techniques and now
you're violating the no self doctrine
okay
so you're here and you go double leg
then no
right even on the lighter person
you can't do it all the time because
it's not fitting it's forcing
so as we as we go you see i'm moving
already in that spiral geometry with
that first step so
he's gonna have to turn this way
or this way to get me i already sought
a tactile connection so he goes albert
we're going this way
you see i found the other hand and
it's more what are you going to do what
do you want to do
say he wants to go low so that's my
technique
come back see if we can get the same
thing
so from the weave he goes
whoa it's not that i go down here we go
i don't do that i let what's happened
happen and what's happening go
is perfectly fine with me so see he's
turning tighter
he wants this leg over here do you see
so
instead of fighting the leg he goes
i move the leg he goes boom
non-confession also means that i'm not
forcing the situation i'm letting the
situation
unfold
never
see the difference okay chinese
the next points brought up is
uh we're we're gonna go right and
i'm trying to trade myself uh
this is not mma this this if you want to
know where does the drill happen
uh so he goes the drill's here when he
shifts his weight like that
so he shifts his weight to his right leg
i know he's not kicking one that leg
okay so already drill started i got out
something that i would be able to use
marshally
outside of this drill okay um
second thing he goes and i'm not ducking
without looking he goes
and i pull right there i just got to
practice a slip
you see am i practicing contestation
no no it's no different than
this punch wants to hit me here
and if i don't stand there by because i
move back
that's non-contestation if in this case
i've moved here
i'm not where the punch is i'm not
contesting for that
same point in space it doesn't mean i'm
now
aggressive or forcing it
or wrestling with him i've moved into
the free space
this is in space this is in space
this is a better in space
then this is a better than this is this
in space
because all he's going to do is come
again
and you will move back again to that in
space okay here we go
come on home next one home
next one next one next one well so much
i'm out of in space
but if i obey my principles and i go
in space he goes to the next one i move
he goes to the next one and i move he
goes to the next one and i move
and he goes to the next one and i move
the spiral
is infinite in this uni space
the line is not
theoretically it is but in terms of
practicality
is not but the spiral is because i'm
just moving into
the space either he was occupying or i
was occupying
so that is a better yin space a better
non-contest station
when i do the other one this skin space
it's i'm always without the initiative
he has it he's going to keep it he keeps
it
he keeps it keeps it i'm never
going to be able to turn this around
until
the theory of the line hits me in the
face
then i'll realize well that didn't work
okay
so i don't ever go
your turn my turn no
his turn is my turn his turn is my turn
whatever he's doing is my turn
if for some reason it's not i can't tell
what he's doing
i took the linear line don't
look this is a bad posture
so to go here go and try to deal with
this i'm not going to be able to do it
so dance out boom start to drill over
again
don't dance out on a straight line
so this is not realistic
no never going to happen real life
you won't have that you won't be able to
reverse that initiative
you're going to be caught the mind is
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
you're going to get your weight back on
your heels you're not going to be able
to do it
so look for the first one
boom that's the one i want
if not the first one maybe the second
one
if i can't get it in one or two if i
can't get a tactile connection
in one or two in training dance out
don't start practicing this weird
understanding of non-contestation
it's not too gypsy
um next thing
again don't chase the technique
don't chase the technique i don't know
what technique i'm going to do
i can read your body i'll move in a way
that i'm not contesting
i'll seek a spirally geometry but i
don't have a technique in mind
okay so what do i have in mind just odds
just odds so as i already said
if you look at it go this is a better
odd
than this so i took that one
he goes this is a better on than staying
here
and trying this so i took that one
he goes boom you see then
i just have connection he goes and i go
with him
he goes he's trying to turn into me you
see the my shrinking
go back he turns into me and i move
let him fall he's trying to come
under do you see what i'm doing with
this hand
so pull this arm off of me can you see
then i follow it in
don't pick your techniques if i don't
know what to do
get out don't know what to do
get out on the angle
if i get the tactile connection boom go
don't pick it keep moving towards the
back keep spiraling
keep yielding go
any technique you get now like this
is not going to work it's not aikido
it's not jiu-jitsu
it's not gonna work even if i can get
this technique on him
here through these mechanical levers
don't do it
okay let's go okay i am reading the body
but as i said i'm not banking on what
i'm reading
okay there's fakes and things and part
of this is
that the untrained mind uh is threatened
by what's happening
and you'll get a tunnel vision or a
hyper focus
on what the threat is so in this case
the threat is everyone at his lens
so he i'm gonna exaggerate it but he's
gonna go and you're like
like this kind of thing but you tend to
do it with your body
so he's gone you're like
this does not work
so leave your hands where they're in
that neutral space
where they can strike and where they can
seek their tactile
ik adhesion okay so i'm here
i can do all that in here you see with
my hands up he keeps going
oh i'm in here like this
so same thing especially on kicks
you're like like this your face is
uncovered
okay so don't chase the strikes around
watch if you keep touching every single
strike nine out of ten times
you're being fettered by the strike all
right so
what i've demonstrated so far is just
this non-contestation
yielding and letting the technique
happen um
you can do all that in a way where your
noggin was that actually comes out
okay but for training if i want to train
the mind of release
and the body of non-attachment i'd like
to just let him land in these weird
grappling
type things okay so we're i'm going to
now open
it up to the nagawaza and you'll see
when you get your turn
you're going to be forcing everything as
you try to find your throws
but the throw is on the tail end of
every one of those non-contest stations
every one of those ik adhesions so so
we're going
right where you get your coq projections
here we go
[Music]
so
okay